>> Peter Vankevich: Well,
it's been a long day
and what a beautiful, wonderful
day it has been certainly
in our fiction stage here.
So Ron Charles, book critic
for the Washington Post
Style section is here
and he will start taking over
with introductions for Ms. Meg.
OK. Welcome.
>> Ron Charles: Thank you.
First, a word of
thanks to our cochairman
of the festival David Robinstein
and other generous sponsors
who've made this event possible.
If you'd like to add
your financial support,
there's a note in the
program, please seek that out.
We'll have some time after this
conversation for your questions.
And I've been asked to remind
you that if you come to one
of these microphones, you will
be included in the video tape
of this event in the
library's permanent collection.
So keep that in mind if you
don't want to be recorded.
My guest today is Meg Wolitzer.
[ Applause ]
The author of "The Ten-Year
Nap" and "The Uncoupling"
and "The Interestings" and more.
But I want to talk and
we will talk about the
"The Female Persuasion".
But first, I want to
talk about "The Wife".
>> Meg Wolitzer: Oh yes.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
"The Wife".
>> Meg Wolitzer: My cousins.
>> Ron Charles: Well,
this came out 15 years ago
and now we're all
talking about it again.
It must be incredibly exciting.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yes, I
brought a sort of show and tell.
So this is the movie tie-in
addition which is very exciting.
And I went and looked
it up on Amazon.
It's number one in movie
tie-in editions, so very proud.
>> Ron Charles: Starring
Glenn Close.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Starring
Glenn Close and Jonathan Pryce.
And I have to say--
I mean, I'm prejudice
but they're incredible.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
I mean people are
talking about Oscars.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
Now, this is very,
very exciting.
>> Meg Wolitzer:
It's very exciting.
>> Ron Charles: How did
the project come about?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Well,
so I wrote this novel.
It came out in 2003.
And the wonderful screenwriter
Jane Anderson got involved
at some point not
too long after that.
And she had a lot of
trouble getting it made.
It was hard getting a
male star who wanted
to play this real jerky guy.
And it was-- the movie
was called "The Wife".
Not only that.
So that was sort of difficult.
But suddenly, things got moved
and Glenn Close got
attached to it.
And she's-- I have to say
she's really brilliant in it.
She's wonderful in it.
Please go-- Oh excellent.
And it got a great review in
the Washington Post which --
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Meg Wolitzer: -- made
me very, very happy.
But it's been really--
having a movie made is sort
of the icing on the cake.
It's like I came up with
those character's names.
Why are famous movie stars
saying them out loud?
>> Ron Charles: So did you
get involved in the script?
>> Meg Wolitzer: No.
You know, somebody-- I had
a book turned into a movie.
It was the first film
that Nora Ephron directed,
"This is My Life" long time ago.
And I was interviewed for
it, and somebody said to me,
"Aren't you afraid what they're
going to do to your book?"
And I said, "My book
is on shelf.
They're going to do what they
do but my book doesn't change."
So I try to sort of leave the
writer to do what she does.
>> Ron Charles: But
what's it like?
You're sitting in a dark room
and you're seeing these
characters you created
up there come to life.
What does it feel like?
>> Meg Wolitzer:
Well, it's really fun.
I mean, it's-- and when
your name gets up there,
it's kind a like you
kind of look down shyly.
You know, it's tremendous
because writing is so solitary.
I mean I'm basically mostly--
like writers are so excited
when we get to go somewhere.
Like coming to the National
Book Festival is sort
of like a dog being taken for
a ride in the car [laughter].
I mean, I am usually at
home in a big t-shirt
that says ultimate
Frisbee or something on it
that I don't play and I don't
know where it came from.
When you get to go somewhere,
it's just really,
really thrilling.
So having a movie made is just--
it's dreamy and it's
not solitary.
That's the thing.
When you go to the set of a film
or a television show that's made
of you, like, they
have to be nice at you.
They take you to the
table craft services
where the food is and feed you.
But the idea of being with
people that there is a group
of people involved with
making something is
so different is the
opposite of what I really do
because I'm just by myself,
talking to myself
in my apartment.
>> Ron Charles: Has there been
some exciting Hollywood moments?
>> Meg Wolitzer: In other
people's lives [laughter]?
Yes, there are a lot.
Well, the new book,
"The Female Persuasion",
Nicole Kidman is
attached to star.
So that was really fun.
But this is like when
you're writing a book,
you don't think about
any of this.
For me, people say do
you picture who's going
to play these parts
and of course, no.
It's a book it's not a movie.
I kind of think that my
characters are sort of like,
you know, if you watch
a reality TV show
which I've heard some people do.
If you want a reality TV show,
the people who don't want
to be photographed
in the background have
their faces blurry.
That's how I picture
my characters.
I don't quite see
their faces but I know
who they are very deeply.
>> Ron Charles: Let's talk
about "The Female Persuasion".
>> Meg Wolitzer: Sure.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
Now, it's about bright, young
college student named Greer
who has a chance encounter
with a feminist icon
woman named Faith,
a kind of glorious item
figure who changes her life.
And your timing feels uncanny.
When did you start this?
Was it long before the
Me Too Movement or?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Around the
time I got that crystal ball.
Yeah. I started it years ago.
I mean somebody asked me in
an interview, did you write it
after the Me Too Movement?
It was like I would have to have
gotten a lot of people together
in a room and I would have
said you take this chapter,
you take that chapter.
Yeah. Because the ideas
in this book are--
I mean, ideas around
female power and mentorship
and misogyny and making
meaning in the world are things
that I had just been
thinking about forever
and I think probably most
of us have been thinking
about forever.
>> Ron Charles: They're
all new problems though.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Well,
we're in a weird moment--
When the book came out,
it was sort like a
game of musical chairs.
You know, it happened to
come out in this moment.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Meg Wolitzer: But it was a
time that people we're talking
in a new way or in
a heightened way
about so many of these issues.
So I certainly had
something to say.
>> Ron Charles: Did the book
change as you were writing it,
as you responded
in your own life
of what was happening
in the world?
>> Meg Wolitzer: The only
thing that I went back
and changed really was
the last chapter because--
I mean, have some of you
read "The Female Persuasion"?
Oh, thank you.
I'm going to have to ask
the rest of you to leave.
This is for those people
who've read it, just for us.
So the book is about
a famous feminist,
as Ron said, in a younger woman.
It's about the person you might
meet who changes your life,
who sees something in you, a
mentor, this famous feminist
who sees a very shy college
student and helps her.
I imagined when I was
writing this book that we--
that when it came out, we would
have the first woman president
as president.
And as some of you may have
heard that didn't happen.
>> Ron Charles: Spoiler alert.
>> Meg Wolitzer: I
know, I hate that.
Don't you hate when
people do that?
I often find-- here's
a big parenthesis.
I often find that when I'm
talking to a group of people
and some have read a
book and some haven't,
you have to thread this needle.
So that you don't bore the
room nor do you ruin things--
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Meg Wolitzer: --
for the rest of them.
It's very, very difficult to do.
But I finished the book
and I felt not quite right
about how it ended it.
And I asked my editor if I
had a little time to go back
into the last chapter.
And I wrote a last chapter
that kind of goes forward.
It goes into the future to
a moment when maybe it's not
that sometimes things are
a little better for women
and sometimes they're
a little worst.
Sometimes maybe the
tablecloth gets rip out from
under everything like
in that magic trick.
And I wanted to kind of speak
to the future a little bit.
So I did go back and
add a last chapter.
>> Ron Charles: Now, you said
about the major themes
is female mentorship.
Were there women like
that in own your life?
Was there a mentor in your life
that made a big difference?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yeah.
There were a couple.
I'll mention two.
One is my mother.
My mother is a novelist
Hilma Wolitzer and she's 88.
And she's just amazing.
She started publishing
in the '60s.
And for her first short story
which to give you a sense
of her mindset at the time.
She was a housewife
in the suburbs.
Her book-- Her story was called
"Today a woman went mad
in the supermarket".
And I'm telling you, she
would have gotten mad
if she hadn't start writing.
Something happened to me when
I gave a reading some years ago
that I put in my novel "The
Interestings" in a kind
of slightly different form.
I was at a reading and
I gave a Q&A afterward.
And a woman stood up said
my daughter really wants
to be a playwright but I know
how I incredibly hard it is
for any one, a woman,
or anyone to make it.
What should I tell her?
And I said well is she
talented and she said yes.
And I said and is she
burning to do this.
And she said yes.
And I said well, I think you
should tell her that's wonderful
because the world will
whittle your daughter down
but a mother never should.
And my mother never did.
And I think that's
partly why I'm here.
So she is the one person
because I think of that as sort
of feminism in action.
But the second person is Nora
Ephron who I mentioned earlier.
She's somebody who--
We became friends
after she directed the
film based on my book.
And she was somebody
who you always wanted
to show your book to-- well,
I always wanted to
show my book to.
She was someone whose
opinion I valued,
who is opinionated
and very, very funny.
And she actually-- I think
one thing that she gave is--
well, I talk in the
book about those people
who give you permission.
Do you know-- Do you have
people like that in your life
that you meet when you're young
and maybe they give you
permission to be a certain self?
I kind of was afraid of being
funny, that it wasn't serious.
And Nora was funny and serious.
And there was a little line that
I put in this book and I thought
about how maybe I wouldn't
have written it if not
for Nora's encouragement
or enjoinment
of certain jokes that I did.
There was a moment where Greer
when she's in school as a child,
she's sort of stuck with
the weird girl in the class,
and they're sitting under the
whiteboard eating Pringles.
And the weird girl says
to her, "Do you ever think
about murdering our teacher?"
No, actually no.
I got it wrong.
"Do you ever think about
poisoning our teacher?"
And Greer says no.
And the girl goes,
yeah, neither do I.
And I thought that that's humor.
That it's not there just for the
sake of itself, but it's there
to show something
about a character
and the way the other
character interacts with her.
And it's worth putting in
even though it stops things
for a moment.
You get something of
the writer's sensibility
and you get more of
the character's world.
>> Ron Charles: Could
you read a bit for us?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Sure, it
will cost you but yeah.
Yeah, I'll just read
the opening.
"Greer Kadetsky met Faith
Frank in October of 2006
at Ryland College, where Faith
had come to deliver the Edmund
and Wilhelmina Ryland
Memorial Lecture.
And though that night the
chapel was full of students,
some of them boiling over
with loudmouthed commentary,
it seemed astonishing but true
that out of everyone there,
Greer was the one
to interest Faith.
Greer, a freshman then at
this undistinguished school
in Southern Connecticut, was
selectively and furiously shy.
She could give answers
easily, but rarely opinions.
'Which makes no sense, because
I am stuffed with opinions.
I am a piñata of opinions,'
she'd said to Cory during one
of their nightly Skype sessions
since college had
separated them.
She'd always been a tireless
student and a constant reader,
but she found it impossible to
speak in the wild and free ways
that other people did.
For most of her life it hadn't
mattered, but now it did.
So what was it about her
that Faith Frank
recognized and liked?
Maybe, Greer thought, it was
the possibility of boldness,
lightly suggested in the streak
of electric blue that zagged
across one side of her otherwise
ordinary furniture-brown hair.
But plenty of college girls had
hair partially dipped the colors
of frozen and spun treats
found at county fairs.
Maybe it was just that Faith,
at 63 a person of influence
and a certain level of fame who
had been traveling the country
for decades speaking
ardently about women's lives,
felt sorry for 18-year-old
Greer, who was hot-faced
and inarticulate that night.
Or maybe Faith was automatically
generous and attentive
around young people who were
uncomfortable in the world.
Greer didn't really know
why Faith took an interest.
But what she knew
for sure, eventually,
was that meeting Faith Frank
was the thrilling beginning
of everything.
It would be a very long time
before the unspeakable end."
So that's just the beginning.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Ron Charles: Tell
us about this title
and its Jane Austen echo.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Oh
my god, you're right.
No, I did know.
I did think of that.
Wasn't there a Monty Python
with a guy whose name was
somebody smokes too much?
And somebody said oh people must
say things too all the time,
it's like what do you mean?
Yes. I love-- I like
declarative titles.
I love that there is a little
Austenian thing in there.
But also it sounds
to me like the title
of a feminist nonfiction book
from the old days, doesn't it,
because it's a little bit
sort of the feminine mystic.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Meg Wolitzer: It
just got those qualities
and the word persuasion.
There's a pun in the title
too because it's really
about those people who persuade
us, who teach us and who we want
to be like in some way.
So that's all part of it.
>> Ron Charles: I
was so fascinated
by the way novel explores
tensions not between men
and women but between women
within the feminist movement--
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: -- between
different generations
of that movement.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yeah, it was--
my last novel, "The
Interestings" was
about everybody who
was exactly my age.
Because I'm really bad at math,
so it made it so easy to sort
of say that year,
she was, you know,
I knew what I was
doing that year.
It was easy.
But this time around,
it was really
about two generations talking
to each other and I got to think
about my own becoming
a feminist.
When I was a kid, I was
in a consciousness racing
group that we started.
And we rode away to the
National Organization
for Women asking for
a list of topics.
And they sent us things like
orgasm and you when we wanted--
when your mom won't listen.
I mean we were so young but
it meant a lot to be talking
to other, you know, girls,
young women about how
we felt about things.
And it just had a
tremendous effect on me.
>> Ron Charles: How would you
characterize those different
generations and their
attitudes about feminism,
when they all identified
as feminist?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Well, you
know, one of the things
that feminism has had to do and
is in the process of continuing
to wrestle with is
to be more inclusive.
>> Ron Charles: Mm-hmm.
>> Meg Wolitzer:
And that's something
that social justice
movements do have to do.
And they have to-- they have
to be willing to change.
And of course, there's
a lot of tension
between the generations
and we've seen that.
That's a real thing.
But one of the things
that I thought
about when I was
writing this novel
because when you're writing
a novel and not a track--
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Meg Wolitzer: -- it's the
characters that we remember.
I mean, somebody said what we
remember of the books we love is
in plot, but character and I
think that's really true for me.
But one thing that occurred
to me is that these women
of a different-- of
different generations
who call themselves feminists,
they grow up in a
different world.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Meg Wolitzer: So their
experiences are different.
But there is this one
experience at the very beginning
of the book, Greer in
her college experienced,
the very beginning, she goes to
a frat party and she's groped
by a frat brother at the party.
And she has this moment
that I wanted to kind of try
to describe where
something happens to her
and she doesn't know, wait
a minute, does this count?
Am I allowed to be
as upset as I am?
Is it an assault?
Is it real?
And so many women I
had spoken to just
over time had an experience in
their life or certainly several
in which something happened
and their face went hot.
And they thought, wait a minute,
is this just what it's going
to be like being female?
Like, it could even be
something very, very small.
And I wanted to track
that because the feeling
of being a woman in the world,
there are some overlaps
regardless of generation.
>> Ron Charles: Interesting.
And another tension
in the book is
between idealism and capitalism.
Faith's organization
is funded by a man
of somewhat questionable
morals, very wealthy man.
And she's willing
to make compromises
that Greer is not, ultimately.
>> Meg Wolitzer: You
know, Greer sees herself.
She's at the beginning of her
career and she imagines things
in a certain perfection.
But when money gets involved,
things always get
messed up, right?
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Meg Wolitzer:
Money and doing good.
To me as a novelist
that's kind of catnip,
the idea of putting
them both together
because you know it's
going to be complicated.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
And if Faith's not-- Faith is
willing to accept the money
and do good things with it,
Greer thinks the money
has to come clean.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yeah.
I mean, those are questions
that are interesting.
Like Faith thinks, well, at
least I'm reaching some people.
I know it's not pure.
I don't take sides.
That's the thing about being
a novelist is I really don't
take sides.
>> Ron Charles: You didn't
think one of them was right,
one of them was wrong, one of
them is being questionable.
>> Meg Wolitzer: I
don't think that way.
>> Ron Charles: You
>> Meg Wolitzer: I mean,
I don't want to do that.
I feel like a novel is a
place where you don't have
to do the every other place
in our lives right now, right?
We go home and we're on the
internet or at least I am
and you have strong
feeling and everything.
It's like in this moment
of the 24-hour news cycle,
everything is a hot take.
I prefer, if I can, to sometimes
be a master of the warm take,
you know, or even lukewarm take.
The idea of just
saying what is it
like for this people,
what is it like?
And not particularly
coming down on sides.
>> Ron Charles: Let's
talk about Cory.
Such a fascinating character.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Sure.
>> Ron Charles: And we're
not giving anything away Cory
of course because--
>> Meg Wolitzer: And not boring,
those who haven't read it.
>> Ron Charles: Exactly.
OK. But he's a young man.
He's on a classic course of male
success and his life changes.
And he is-- Is he kind
of a male feminist hero?
Is that too much to say?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Well, one
of the things that I got--
I always hesitated to
use the word learned.
There was Seinfeld, I
think, there was a mandate
that they had for the show.
No hugging, no learning.
I feel that way a little
bit about my novels.
But one of the things that I
did kind of learn, I guess,
is that you follow your
characters where your ideas,
the imperative of the
book, will take them.
And I started to see that
in this book that deals
with a famous feminist,
this cool--
she wears sexy boots
and she's well known.
And she has certain--
a catchphrase almost.
She-- And then, someone who
works for her foundation.
What about the people
who just quietly go
and do good every day?
As one of the-- the best friend
in the book in an argument--
big fight scene says I think
there are two kind of feminists,
the famous ones and
everyone else.
And that's what it's like
I think for people who--
you don't have to say I'm
political or I am a feminist
but you can do feminist or
good work in your lives.
And I think one of the
other things of the book is
about doing-- making
meaning for yourself.
And Cory has a tragedy
in his family and ends
up not having this big
consulting job but staying home
and taking care of his mother.
And she cleans houses and he
starts cleaning her houses.
And it's seen as women's work.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Meg Wolitzer:
So yeah, I really--
I liked getting to
know that story.
>> Ron Charles: Cory, yeah.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: I did too.
I was of course surprised as
everyone is who reads the novel
about what happens to him
and really moved by
the way he reacts.
A few years ago, you wrote an
essay called "The Second Shelf".
You wrote in there women's
fiction is relegated
to that closed cornered
lower shelf
for books emphasizing
relationship
and the interior lives of women.
Has that affected your work?
You seem very successful.
It's-- That's hard to believe
that such prejudice affected
the marketing of your own books.
>> Meg Wolitzer: I don't--
I wouldn't say the marketing
of my own books but
certainly we've seen that.
One of the things I talked about
in the piece was the way books
by men and women, you know,
have looked over time.
And you might have what I sort
of a little snidely called
little girl in a field of wheat
on a cover, you know, in
a book that was by a woman
and you would have this sort
of big boldface type in a book
by a man that sort of said
this book is in event.
In addition to little
girl in a field of wheat,
there's another kind of book
though that I sort of women
in water, the dreamy
and essential book.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> Meg Wolitzer:
I guess the thing
about those books is you can
understand publishers wanting
to find audiences but books that
seem to exclude the possibility
of welcoming readers, that's not
what I would want for my book.
The idea of-- picture two men
standing on a train platform.
"What's that you're reading?"
"The little girl in
a field of wheat."
"Oh, yeah, I loved it.
I read it."
"Did you read the sequel, little
girl in the field of rye?"
You know, you can't see it.
You-- The idea of fiction as
being inclusive because we all--
Look, there was that
study that said
that fiction teaches empathy.
We all knew that, we just didn't
have the data for it in advance.
But I think one of the things
that made me start writing
that piece, and I talk
about this in that piece,
was I was at a party and I met
a man and he heard I was writer.
Well, first, he said-- he
asked me the worst question.
Don't ever ask this of a writer.
He asked the worst question.
He said, "Would I
have heard of you?"
It's a terrible question.
There is one really
good answer though,
in a more just world [laughter].
But-- [applause].
But he said, would
I have heard of you
and he asked me to
describe my books.
And I, you know, what themes did
I write about and I, you know,
men, women, sexual
power, marriage.
And his eyes sort of started
rolling up in his head.
And he was like you
should talk to my wife.
And he just got out of
there as fast as he could.
So that started me thinking.
>> Ron Charles: About what
men and women want to read?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yeah.
And why? And are we
programmed for that?
And how can we change that?
Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: There
isn't that much difference
between the great
novels women write
and the great novels men writes
but they are marketed in--
>> Meg Wolitzer:
Sometimes they are.
I hope things are changing.
It's hard to know
where, you know,
we're seeing some
signs of change.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Meg Wolitzer: You know,
Jesmyn Ward has won the
National Book Award twice.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Right?
So-- But you know what,
you write the books
you want to write.
I mean I want to write the books
that I want to write and hope
that readers respond
as they will.
Because, you know,
reading fiction--
Look, being in a convention
center, if I have to be
in a windowless place all day,
you were the people
I want to be with.
Because we love fiction.
And that's not-- It's
more really about that.
Like, we live in such
a nonfiction world.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Meg Wolitzer: You know, our
lives are anxious and we're
on mind, you know, stalking old
boyfriends or I've heard tell.
But actually, I will say this.
The internet has had certainly
a bad effect on some--
on writing and reading
in so many ways.
You could be writing like
a super lyrical passage
and you need to take
a break from it.
You go online and
you see best resorts.
And you start looking at a
list of the best resorts.
And now you go back to
your lyrical passage
and it suddenly takes
place in Aruba.
You know, I feel that the
distractions are so profound--
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Meg Wolitzer: -- that we need
to force ourselves
away from them.
But being among readers
is so hopeful.
It-- Because reading matters.
I mean, when you think about,
you can't quantify the ways
in which reading
fiction is so important.
But all I need to do
is imagine a culture
where there were
no novels in it.
It just-- It's just-- I get
so much from reading fiction.
I feel so moved by
reading about other people.
>> Ron Charles: The book has
been out about four months.
Have you had interesting
experiences with women coming up
and telling you their own
experiences with their lives,
their response to
the Me Too Movement?
Is it, yeah, is it
calling out that kind
of response among your readers?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Well, one thing
that's happened is I have signed
a lot like a copy for
someone and her daughter.
>> Ron Charles: Nice.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: Very nice.
>> Meg Wolitzer: So that's
been really, really nice.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yeah, I
think when you meet a reader
and you hear a story about
how something affected them,
it's wonderful.
People-- One thing actually in
October before the book came
out long ago, almost a year ago,
my publisher had a
little media event.
And everyone was given a
little nametag and they had
to write someone who
had been an influence
to them when they were young.
There were a lot of Michelle
Obamas and some dance teachers.
But everybody-- It
was a great icebreaker
because if you had someone
who saw something in you
when you were younger,
you haven't forgotten it.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
Yeah. Now this hasn't been
so serious about the book,
but the book is really funny.
You are really funny
as they can tell.
How do you-- When you're
writing, you're alone
as you said, how can you tell
if what you're writing
is in fact funny?
>> Meg Wolitzer: I can't.
You know how you-- You
know what's it like,
the horrible thing about writing
a novel is in terms of humor,
well, there are many horrible
things about writing a novel.
Where to begin?
>> Ron Charles: Let's
stick to the humor part.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Where to begin?
But when I give like the
first reading from a book--
>> Ron Charles: Yeah, yes.
>> Meg Wolitzer:
-- and people laugh
at something like-- I'm like--
>> Ron Charles: Is
it a surprise?
>> Meg Wolitzer: --
wait, that was meant
to be lyrical and moving.
Why are you laughing at that?
Or surprised when they
laugh at another line.
It's sort of as if you made a
very grand recipe and tested it
out in front of the queen of
England for the first time.
I mean, you don't know
if it's funny or not
until you read it aloud.
Because I don't sit
there trying to--
nobody cracks themselves up.
I mean comedians don't.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Right.
They sit there, you
know, grimly.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
>> Meg Wolitzer:
No, I never know.
>> Ron Charles: Interesting.
>> Meg Wolitzer: But I know--
But again, it's about
sensibility.
I guess the thing is
with writing humor,
it's not insert joke here.
It's Mad Libs.
It's just-- It has
to-- It often comes
out of character or sensibility.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
Now you're working
at a new novel called
"To Night Owl from Dogfish".
>> Meg Wolitzer:
It's coming out.
It's done.
>> Ron Charles: It's done.
>> Meg Wolitzer: It's
a kid's book, yeah.
>> Ron Charles: For
us it's coming out--
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: -- in February?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Right.
Tell-- Can you tell
us anything about it?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Sure.
I wear at least two hats.
And I do write books
for kids and this is
for middle grade readers.
It's so funny when I refer
to my adult fiction, I--
it sounds like porn,
my adult novels,
the ones with the plain covers.
But this book is co-written with
Holly Goldberg Sloan who wrote
"Counting by 7s" of some of you.
Yeah. OK. Great.
And she's just-- It's a novel
told in emails and letters
from two girls whose fathers are
single gay dads and fall in love
and want the girls
to be friends.
And there's a summer
camp plot because as with
"The Interestings", I can't
stay away from summer camp.
It was a very important
experience in my life.
I went to summer-- to an
arts summer camp and I was
so pretentious at this camp.
Every play that I was in, I
used what can only be described
as my Katharine Hepburn voice.
It could be a Neil Simon
comedy or The House
of Bernarda Alba by Lorca.
And I was like mother,
where are you?
Where are you, mother?
You know, I just could
not break out of that.
And I was super-- I
would carry that summer--
I wanted so much to be
sort of intellectual.
I would carry a book under my
arms so people could see it,
and just like parts of it.
It would say "The
Magic Mountain"--
like, you could not
quite see the whole title
of "The Magic Mountain".
I would carry it under my arm.
And I also started
writing in a diary thinking
that maybe I would
be sort of a member
of like the Bloomsbury Group
like the Long Island
version someday.
And I started writing
very faithfully
in my diary every day.
Like today, I watched
Bewitched and then [laughter]--
and then I stop, I forgot.
And I got oh no, months
later, I found the diary.
I was like, oh no, I
better write in it.
And I went back and I
wrote on every page,
nothing happened today.
[Laughter] Cleaver.
That's the long answer
to your question about--
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Meg Wolitzer:
It was completely
unrelated children's book.
I'm so sorry.
>> Ron Charles: Did
you construct the novel
as email back and forth?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yes.
Well, here's the
funny thing that--
>> Ron Charles: I mean she
wrote half and you wrote half?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Well, what
happened was Holly's husband--
When Holly and I met at a kid's
book conference actually and--
because I had written
a book for--
a young adult book and
a book for kids as well,
and she had these
wonderful books.
And we talked about
writing a book together.
And her husband said,
"Why don't you
and Meg send emails
to each other?"
And we thought he meant do
it as a novel in emails.
He said, "Oh I never meant that.
I meant just kick around ideas."
But it turned out to be--
Right away, I started writing
in this sort of highly
neurotic voice.
I don't know where
I got my ideas.
And-- But then we went back
and we aren't either character.
They're two very
different girls.
But we went and sort of
overwrote each others parts.
And both of the girls, both
of the characters
are very much in us.
So we wrote the whole thing
separately and together.
>> Ron Charles: How fun.
What ages is that for?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Like 10 and up.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
How fun that would be.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yeah.
>> Ron Charles: The last--
>> Meg Wolitzer: It's so weird.
We're like, what age is this?
What age is this for?
Oh, you know, it's like--
>> Ron Charles: Yeah, 22 to 65
>> Meg Wolitzer: Right, 22
through the AARP years, yes.
>> Ron Charles: And last
year, you edited a volume
of Great American Short Stories.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Best
American Short Stories, yes.
>> Ron Charles: So that meant
you read a lot of short stories.
You may be the current expert
on what's being written
in short stories of American?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yes I am.
I--
>> Ron Charles: Do
you have any wisdom?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Well, I
think that short story--
the short story is alive
and well in this country.
There-- There's not
any one kind of thing.
>> Ron Charles: You must have
seen just tremendous variety
to choice from.
>> Meg Wolitzer: I did.
It's really hard to do to put
it together but I laid them
out all-- you know, on my--
in the floor in my apartment
and walked around them and
picked them and it was great.
It was really exciting to put
something like that together.
>> Ron Charles: Not bad.
Not bad. Would you
take some questions?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yeah, I will.
>> Ron Charles: OK.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Sure.
>> Ron Charles: About
any of the books.
We've got a microphone
here and here.
Just come up and Meg
will point to you.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yeah.
>> Hi
>> Meg Wolitzer: Hi.
>> I was introduced to you
by my daughter who gave me
"Female Persuasion"
for Mother's Day.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Oh, great.
>> And I'm now learning
about your work backwards
on a timeline.
I've just finished
"The Everythings".
And it seems to me particularly
listening to you today
that there is a similarity
between Greer and Jules in terms
of their-- at least in the
beginning of the development
of the characters,
they're insecure,
they're not very self-aware.
And we see them really grow
and become more powerful
as they get older.
And of course I've only
read these two books
but I just wonder if
you do make connections
to characters either
willingly or not?
>> Meg Wolitzer: I think that
I don't do it consciously
but I think it's
definitely there.
I mean, I don't like to
write autobiographically.
I don't think either of
those characters is me
but it doesn't come from outer
space, it comes from something
like you're marinating
in these ideas.
I gave a reading-- an event
at Ann Patchett's bookstore.
Wonderful bookstore Parnassus
and she was asking me questions
from the stage about--
and I said something like,
I think everybody maybe has
like three or four arias
to sing and Ann said one.
And that may be true that we
are a person living in the world
so there's going to be a kind
of Venn diagram overlap
I think among characters.
Sure.
>> Thank you.
I love your work.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Thank you.
>> Hi, my friend wanted me to
ask about the end of "The Wife".
And I did not read your book
so I apologize right now.
But now I'm going to read it now
that I've seen the movie
and it's out there.
But is she writing her story at
the end when she turns the page
and she's on the airplane?
Does that coincide
with your book?
Or like you said, you
didn't have to take
in the-- of the movie.
>> Meg Wolitzer: The movie is a
little different from the book.
You're talking about
the movie, right?
>> Right.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yeah, the
movie is a little different
from the book.
>> How are we supposed
to interpret the
ending of the movie?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Oh.
>> Did you-- at the end of it.
>> Meg Wolitzer: I would
never tell anyone how
to interpret an ending.
I also kind of feel with--
when you leave your
characters behind, I leave--
do you remember in "The
Truman Show" when he discovers
that the world is
sort of enclosed?
I kind of feel like my
characters are in a snow globe
but I'm sort of leaving
them there.
But without a doubt, at
the end of "The Wife",
certainly at the end of
the novel of "The Wife"
and in the firm,
there is a new moment
for this character Joan
Castleman, who was the wife
of the famous bloated novelist.
I think that I would hesitate
to be more specific than that.
>> OK.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Sorry.
>> Ron Charles: Have you ever
gone back written a sequel
of any kind?
>> Meg Wolitzer: No.
No. I mean, I guess
I love leaving--
It's not exactly leaving
things up to interpretation,
but I would say that she's--
the difference between the book
and the firm is-- one
of the differences.
Well, one thing is
they made the--
I made up a prize that the
husband wins called the
Helsinki Prize.
It's like two or three
steps down from the Nobel.
They made it the Nobel
Prize in the movie
that the novelist husband wins.
But I sort of loved the idea
of her-- she's in first person,
the novel is in first person,
and it's funny and angry.
And the firm it's all
in Glenn Close's face
in so much close-ups of her, and
so much of what she finally gets
to say as it starts to unfold.
We definitely know
that she's moving
into something knew
in both cases.
>> Right. Thank you.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Sure, thanks.
>> Hi, Meg, it's good
to see you again.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Hello.
>> Hi. We grew up together,
Meg and I in the same
street in Syosset.
>> Meg Wolitzer: This is true.
This is true.
>> I have a comment.
I don't read a lot of fiction
but when your book came out,
I went to our local library and
I said, please order this book.
So I filled out the form and
I got the book and I read it
and I thought I'm so glad you
wrote a book about feminists,
feminist history and feminism
because I thought
man it's about time.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Nice
to see you, Terry.
>> Yeah.
>> Hi. I'm a big fan of you
novel, "Belzhar" personally
because it incorporates
talking about writing
as therapy while not making
overshadow the other elements
of the novel.
So how did you make that balance
of talking about the need
for writing and the
need for expression
but also incorporating other
elements of story time?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Thank you.
So I wrote this young adult
novel that she's referring
to called "Belzhar" which is
kind of a play on "The Bell Jar"
which is a book that was
really important to me.
It takes place at a school
for highly intelligent
troubled teenagers.
I would have killed
to go to that school.
I have to say.
>> Ron Charles: You
weren't troubled enough?
>> Meg Wolitzer: I
wasn't troubled enough.
And as you know, I had
to stay in Syosset.
But the characters in the
novel are put into a class
where they write in a
journal and when they write--
there's a kind of sort
of fantasy element.
They write in a journal and
they sort of brought to a moment
of where a crisis
happened in their lives.
I feel expression is everything.
Being able to say what you feel.
We say it politically
with the Me Too Movement.
We see it with writers.
The need to hear how-- what
someone's experience was.
It's terribly important.
So, yeah, that was
important to them especially
at a moment of adolescence.
I mean, one of the reasons I
like writing about teenagers is
because it's a time of firsts
and that definitely
comes across in the book.
I hope. Thank you.
>> So I'm going to
ask you very boring
and cliché author question.
It's about characterization
specifically Greer
and Faith Frank.
I just-- I'm just
curious about the lens
in which you wrote these very
lovable flawed characters,
sort of you process, and I know
they're meticulously detailed
down to the Blue Streak Tier
[assumed spelling], the boots,
but I just wanted to know I
guess like what inspired you
for their traits, did
it come naturally?
Or was it something that
was more prescribed?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Thank you.
Coming up with character
to me is,
it's sort of you can't force it.
You know a little bit and then
you know a little bit more.
Kind of like a rip
gets worst and worst
and hopefully this is
the opposite of a rip,
it gets better and better.
But I think of character
this way.
You know how you're at home
and you suddenly want to talk
to a particular friend.
It-- And there may be nothing
you need to tell that friend
and there may be nothing
you need to hear news-wise
from that friend, but you feel
the desire to speak to them.
I feel that that thing
that you can't quite name,
the way the room temperature
changes when you talk
to that friend, character
ought to be that way.
So that when a character
comes into being on the page,
there's a certain feeling.
And then when she returns later,
that feeling might return too.
It's almost like a theme in
like "Peter and the Wolf",
like there is a sense of that.
And the more you get
to know her, the more--
or him, the more that comes
about through being aware
of how are things shifting
when that character is there?
I just try to explore
that a little bit,
and then the details
kind of come,
and that's the pleasurable
stuff.
It's like a waterfall
of details.
Faith wearing boots.
I knew she was a
charismatic figure.
But then I wanted
to make it specific.
She's so charismatic.
She's so exciting to people.
There's-- The "Female
Persuasion" is kind
of dual love story.
It's a love story between Greer
and her boyfriend and also
between Greer and Faith, this
feminist who inspires her.
And the idea of someone
who you really look up to,
let's give her hair, let's
give her boots, and Faith--
and then we know her in a way.
So it comes about
that way, I think.
Thank you.
>> I read "The Female
Persuasion" and I loved it
and I've been looking
at articles
and seeing people talk about it.
And people talk so much about
the relationship between Faith
and Greer and also about
Cory's development,
but I don't see a lot of
people talking so much
about the character of
Zee and I don't want
to be spoilerly [phonetic]
about anything,
but I just thought her
journey was so interesting.
I mean beyond what
happened with Greer,
I thought that her
personal journey
about her inner city school
teaching and what she learned
about herself and about the
world was so interesting,
and I wonder if you could
comment on her character.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Oh, thank you.
Yeah. I mean, I guess the
problem when you write a novel
that has multiple
characters and different--
multiple perspectives,
it's hard to, you know,
for reviews to get everyone in.
It could feel a little
bit like a big--
a lot of people at the table.
This is-- I love writing
about female friendship
or about friendship
really which happens
to often be female
friendship but not always.
In "The Interestings", the
friendship between Jules
and Ethan was a big
thing for me.
I think friendship is enormously
powerful and shifting, and it--
when I was a kid,
I thought that you
and your friends would
be together forever.
Like that it would be like that
it would be like an episode
of Sex and the City where
you're always at the same table.
It isn't like that.
I mean, I have friends,
you don't see for decades
but the minute you see them,
you continue that thing.
That's what life is more like.
So Greer and his best friend,
Zee is sort of a young activist.
She's queer.
She's full of heart in someway.
But I think their
friendship reaches a point
where Greer does
something that's not great.
And again, here is that moment
of threading the needle,
not wanting to give things away.
People go, I would've read
"The Female Persuasion"
but she told me what happened,
so I don't I don't
need to read it now.
I like writing about the
tensions between them
but the love that
you have for friends
over a long period of time.
>> Thank you.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Thank you.
>> Thank you so much.
On page 45 of your
book, which I--
>> Meg Wolitzer: Oh, yes.
Oh, yes, I know.
I know what you're
going to bring up.
>> Yes. You wrote that you
believe a paraphrase by the way,
that the most effective
people on the earth are people
who are introverts who taught
themselves to be extroverts.
And that really resonated
with me many, many ways
and I'm wondering to what
extent did you see yourself
as the introvert who
became the extrovert?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Oh, completely.
Completely.
I remember like last week my
face going so hot and feeling
like you can't speak but force--
but really, but forcing yourself
to do it and seeing what the
bounty you reap doing it.
No, I mean, it's very,
very hard to speak up
and you have this one moment to
get anyone's attention, right?
And if you miss it-- I remember
like being a kid and being
at one of those horrible
parties in someone's basement
with the hang in there
baby poster, right,
you remember that, the
cat hanging onto a bar?
>> Ron Charles: It's
very inspiring.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Yes,
right, it-- that's right.
It's really inspiring.
>> Ron Charles: We're
still here.
>> Meg Wolitzer: That's
right, just hanging in there.
And the one that said, keep
on trucking and just being
at a party and working
myself up to say a joke.
And as I went to
go for the joke,
someone else said something
funny, and that was it.
I missed it.
It was like jump rope.
And the idea that if you
can be more comfortable,
because no one is
thinking about you as much
as you're thinking
about yourself.
Once I realized that,
I think it was easier
to talk a little more freely.
But yeah, I absolutely
think that's me.
>> Thank you.
I loved, truly loved your book.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Thank you.
>> And I want everybody
in the room to read it.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Thank you.
Thank you.
>> I just-- Can I?
I just saw "The Wife" yesterday
and just incredibly loved it.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Thank you.
>> And I haven't read
the book but based
on the different endings I'm
going to go get the book now.
I would really like to know,
where did that story come from
or how did you come up
with that story or what--
were there-- did
something happen?
Did you run into somebody?
Did you start with an idea?
I mean--
>> Meg Wolitzer: OK, first
of all, see the ending,
it's not that different.
The book is pretty
faithful really.
The movie is-- The
book is faithful
to the movie [laughter].
God, the movie is faithful to
the book in very important ways.
I grew-- because I grew up
with a mother who is a writer,
I was sort of looking
around at writers.
And my mother, when
she-- I know that she--
when she first published her
first novel, the headline of one
of the reviews said something
like housewife turns
into novelist.
She said it was as if she
went into a phone booth
and came out as Superman.
You would think it was such
a, you know, huge thing to do
for a housewife to
turn into a novelist,
a certain kind of condescension.
And I thought, what if I wrote
a book from the point of view
of this woman who was-- wives
are-- the idea of the wife,
people who would sort of maybe
want to get to the big man
and go to the wife to sort
of as a sneaky way in,
what secrets does the wife of
this big man from this era have?
And I started-- And I went
to Smith College before
I transferred to Brown
and I was a big, as I said,
a reader of "The Bell
Jar" and Sylvia Plath.
And Plath, Plathiana is all
over that place, Northampton,
Massachusetts and Smith College.
And I wrote about a character--
my character Joan when
she's young has an affair
with her professor and
falls in love with him.
He leaves his wife and she goes
off and becomes this big writer.
And it's a book full of rage
and humor and I didn't have
to keep them separate.
And I just thought about--
I just thought about writers
and what it's been like,
the mid-century male writers
and the notion of
male importance
and how we've looked
at that over time.
But what if I did that
but it wasn't a polemic.
It was funny and
angry all at once.
So it was a great relief
and a pleasure to write.
>> Ron Charles: One more.
>> Meg Wolitzer: OK.
>> So I wanted to let you know
I have a male voice and that I,
as a male, really
enjoyed your work.
And I actually wanted
to ask a question
of Ron if you don't mind.
>> Ron Charles: We
could talk afterwards.
>> Do you think Meg's work ought
to be required reading
for modern males?
[Laughter] Typically
in this day and age?
>> Ron Charles: Definitely.
>> Yes.
>> Ron Charles: Yes.
>> OK. So we agree on that.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Good
answer as they say
on Family Feud [laughter].
>> Ron Charles: We
became friends years ago.
So I haven't been able to
review her work in the paper
but I certainly read it
and enjoy it definitely
and learn a lot from it.
>> I know I had a conversation
with you earlier, Meg,
about how you've helped to start
many conversations in my family
with my daughter and my wife.
So thank you very much for that.
>> Meg Wolitzer: My pleasure.
>> And I wished you-- you
should start a conversation
in our society as a whole
about some of these issues.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> Meg Wolitzer:
I appreciate that.
Great. [Applause] Wait, she--
>> Ron Charles: We
can take one more.
>> Meg Wolitzer:
Yeah, we can take it.
>> Ron Charles: Yeah.
>> Meg, I want to ask you
something very self-absorb,
is it possible I could speak
to you after the presentation?
>> Meg Wolitzer: Sure.
>> Thanks.
>> Meg Wolitzer:
Everyone come speak to me.
One at a time, I will give
you each a real moment
of bonding, but yes.
>> Ron Charles: Well, thank
you for this moment of bonding.
>> Meg Wolitzer: Thank
you very much for coming.
>> Ron Charles: It's been a
real pleasure to talk to you.
>> Meg Wolitzer:
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]